kelly d'un petit cadeau juste pour vous
avant d'avoir la réflexion de jean
michel maire vous avez reçu une boîte de
chocolats vélos fleuris c'est pas une
ban
ces sales blancs en forme de coeur c'est
pas du tout une blague et il ya un mot
avec est ce que vous pouvez le dire je
n'ai pas lu moi alors j'ai pas eu grand
tort
je suis comme cette boîte de chocolats
gérard depardieu lui
je vais être tag gourmandise que tu me
prenne entre tes doigts et enfin fondre
dans ta bouche
c'est alors derrière la boîte de
chocolats c'est vrai que c'est gad
elmaleh le moment je me suis permis de
l'écrire mais gagne à mal et vous a
vraiment envoyer une boîte de jeu te
permettre si c'est juste la boîte où il
peut gagner des points là se trouve ça
mignon c'est vrai ma mère c'est parce
qu'ils étaient moi je t'ai offert un
repas mais là aujourd'hui c'est un peu
veinards paillard à la cantine oui un
repas il suit toute mon admiration
cet aveu gad j'attends les chimiques ses
prunes ban s'est vraiment gagner envoyez
vite leur fière aujourd'hui la boîte de
chocolats il vous aime bien ce qu'il
voit mais avec des chocolats on peut
entraîner mais de faire fléchir
non j'ai des bounties elle a l'habitude
avec maxime guennic la série soit
l'intérieur ces gars tu viens je suis
prêt à l'affronter en duel de la soirée
jusqu'à le contraire bon alors entendu
elles s'étaient affrontées pour une
autre armée par toi et on a livré un
cadeau c'est toi ben non
les malades à l'écran 10000 unien de
péter l'écran voilà j'avais sans
s'emballe à récupérer